[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi.
And welcome to episode number
43 of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm,
as always, very happy.
Very happy we have one of
my friends, Brandon Philips,
CTO of CoreOS.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
He's going to come talk to
us about how they use gRPC
at CoreOS.
It's a really
interesting conversation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Specifically about
etcd but also like
are you using it somewhere else?
A very, very interesting
conversation, really.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and how they really
kind of made the decision to
make that move over as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah, why gRPC, not REST,
why not something else?
It's very interesting.
I'm sure people will like it.
And after that, we'll have one
question of the week, which
is about DataStore.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Local testing with DataStore.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We don't talk that
often about DataStore,
so I like it that we're going
to be mentioning something
as basic, really,
as storing data.
How do you test storing data
and make your test not be flaky?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It sounds really good.
But before we get into that,
we have our usual Cool Things
of the Week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's been renamed, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It is now
Cool Things of the Week.
Absolutely.
The first one is just a
huge favorite of mine.
A gentleman by the name of
Notch or his real name--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I found
out he actually has a name.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
Markus Persson.
If you know Minecraft at all--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I've heard about it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's a thing.
It's a thing.
I just have to mention it,
because he tweeted today
about Google Cloud Platform.
He said, "not only does
everything just work,
Google Cloud also tries
to make you save money.
5 out of 5.
Would cloud again."
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, which
is a pretty amazing tweet.
I also really like-- I
went through all the tweets
he wrote about the topic.
And he also said "the main thing
I like about Google Cloud, it's
super duper user friendly."
So I think that this is also an
invitation, an open invitation
for Notch to come talk to us.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, Notch,
if you're listening,
we would love to
have you on the show.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Please.
MARK MANDEL: Please.
Please come.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
would be pretty awesome.
And we said there were
Cool Things of the Week.
So there's a second one.
MARK MANDEL: There's
a second one.
So this is also kind of cool.
I am not a .NET or
Windows developer,
but we have some new tools
available for those people that
are, which I think is
really, really awesome.
So those people who are
used to running PowerShell
inside a Windows environment,
I hear it's kind of stiffy.
There's a bunch of G
Cloud command line tools
that are available now
for handling like your GCE
instances, cloud SQL instances,
and your cloud storage buckets.
So if you want to manage
your Windows instances,
say through your Command
Line Client, you can do so,
which I think is
really, really neat.
And the other tool that
we also have available
is the Cloud Tools
for Visual Studio.
Right now, it's pretty simple.
It's just basically a
Google Cloud Explorer.
So, again, same
subset of features--
Compute Engine, Cloud
SQL, and Cloud Storage
you can actually go see
in there and be like, OK,
what pieces do I have?
What zones are they in?
What regions are they in?
And you have a nice
way of visualizing
it right through your IEE
their in Visual Studio.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah
and, on top of that,
there's also Cloud Minute Video.
Cloud Minute Videos-- I think
we've never mentioned them,
but they're basically
just one-minute video--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --stuff.
And they teach you how to
do something very specific.
We have one about how to install
Cloud Tools for Visual Studio.
So we'll have a bunch of
links from the show notes
to all of those resources.
So if you are a Windows
developer and you use NET,
.NET Tools on Google Cloud, that
will be very useful for you,
I'm sure.
And I think that it
is time to go talk
to Brandon Philips from CoreOS.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good to me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Let's do that.
So I'm very excited to welcome
to the podcast a friend of mine
and CTO of CoreOS.
Hi, Brandon.
Brandon Philips,
how are you doing?
BRANDON PHILIPS: Great.
Thanks for having me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
always a pleasure.
So I guess that most
people know what CoreOS is,
but could you tell
us what CoreOS does
and what do you do at CoreOS?
BRANDON PHILIPS: Sure.
So CoreOS is a company that's
building a bunch of distributed
system software, and
people have probably
heard of us for a few
different products-- quay.io is
our Container Registry.
CoreOS Linux is kind of
namesake of the company,
is an operating system
for running containers.
And Tectonic is a
distribution of Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And could you tell
us a little bit
about what do you do at CoreOS.
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yeah.
So my role at CoreOS is CTO.
So we started the
company with kind
of the vision of how do we
rebuild infrastructure software
and make it easier to
work with and easier
to secure infrastructure
software and that sort
of thing.
And so we've been kind
of pursuing that mission
as software engineer,
as architect,
as open source leader,
that sort of thing,
for the last three years.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, so I know that CoreOS
has a very popular, definitely
here at Google,
product called at etcd.
Can you tell us a little
bit about what that is
and what it's used for
and where people use it?
BRANDON PHILIPS: Sure.
So etcd is a consensus
key value store.
For a lot of folks, that is
a large mouthful of words.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
BRANDON PHILIPS: But
really what it means
is that a set of machines
inside of a data center--
let's say you have
five machines-- are
able to store data.
They will do it consistently,
and if one of those machines
dies or loses power or
whatever, the key values
that were stored there are
in the exact same state,
replicated in the exact same
way, on the other machines.
And this is really
important, because you
want to start to do things--
when you have lots of machines,
you want to make a
decision, and you
want to ensure that
decision is replicated
and consistent across
all the machines.
So you want to
take a lock or you
want to update some load
balancer configuration
or you want to update
some DNS configuration,
you want to ensure
that there is only one
true configuration
of the cluster,
particularly as you scale
up to lots of machines
inside of your infrastructure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I have an extra
question about etcd,
which is what does it mean?
BRANDON PHILIPS: Sure.
So we were trying to be
really cute with the name.
So the idea is that you hold
onto really important cluster
configuration,
but it's a DAEMON.
It's like a system service.
And so slash etc on a single
machine-- like E-T-C--
is where you hold onto
configuration of a single host,
but in the case of
a DAEMON, you're
going to want to hold
onto that same data,
so it's etc DAEMON-- etcd.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That makes sense.
Cool.
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yeah.
Product marketing wasn't
a strong suit of CoreOS
when we were four people.
MARK MANDEL: And
since coming from me,
it will seem less biased.
What language is
etcd written in?
BRANDON PHILIPS: etcd
is written in Go.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's actually how I heard
about etcd for the first time.
And then some time
ago, I saw a talk
where you explained how etcd
was moving from REST to gRPC.
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yes.
So etcd, when we
started to build etcd,
one of the goals-- we had three
goals-- one of the goals was we
wanted to make distributed
systems easy to consume,
and that goal was
achieved by using REST.
We wanted to make it so that
it was runtime reconfigurable
so it fits into these
cloud environments,
so you can add
and remove members
from a cluster and
that sort of thing.
And then we wanted to build
it using modern technologies
and modern languages like Go.
And so we started with REST as
an easy-to-consume endpoint.
But as etcd started to
get adopted by projects
like Kubernetes, which have
larger and larger scaling
requirements, the REST decision
ended up becoming a bottleneck.
It started to show up as one
of the factors in the scaling
and performance of etcd.
And so we started looking
around at various solutions,
and gRPC was open
sourced about, I guess,
18 months ago-- at least when
we started to look at it.
And so we'd already
started using protobuf
as the internal protocol and
kind of layering on htb2.
And protobuf on the client
protocol as an option
was pretty compelling
in order to flatten out
that kind of growth in
memory and CPU consumption
that we were seeing as we
were trying to scale etcd up
to large Kubernetes workloads.
MARK MANDEL: So
that's interesting.
What sort of scaling or
performance increases
were you able to see
moving over to gRPC?
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yeah.
So we saw several, like
10-- well, let's see.
It was like 2 to 5x on
memory and CPU improvements
by moving over.
And, really, it just
comes down to etcd
has a lot of complex
data structures
that get encoded to JSON.
And so just simply moving to a
format that's more efficient,
like protobuf, causes
just less chatter
on the wire, less bytes when
you're trying to encode it,
and that sort of thing.
So it's really a pretty
straightforward, understandable
how we got there with
the improvements.
And then htb2, we were
able to see really
a big concern in these
databases is file descriptors.
So as you get more and more
users of your database, which
is great, there are
natural constraints
of an operating system.
And one of those things
is file descriptors.
And so being able to multiplex
lots and lots of requests
from a single client
onto a single TCP stream
was a nice win on actually
the inside of the CPU memory
side, the operating system
networking side of the system.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And is this
available now in etcd
or is this something that's
coming in a future version?
What's the timeline there?
BRANDON PHILIPS:
Yeah, so etcd v3,
which was released
about three months ago,
introduced the v3 API, which is
accessible as both the REST API
and it is a gRPC API.
So it's available today.
It's being used in
a lot of projects.
We did upstream work in
Kubernetes to enable v3 usage.
And then because gRPC has all
these great language bindings,
we're actually
starting to see things
like a Java client
come out for etcd v3
and a bunch of other
clients that kind of got
built automatically.
So it's been a
nice adoption curve
over the last two or three
months as we released etcd v3.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you mentioned that the v3
API is both in gRPC and REST.
How do you manage that?
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yeah.
So the way that we
do that is there's
a really great project that
is called the gRPC Gateway.
And the cool thing about gRPC
is that it's very declarative,
and it declares essentially
the verb, the noun,
the nouns like what you're
actually operating on.
And using this gRPC
Gateway Library,
you're able to flatten that
down into a REST endpoint.
So you're able to say,
well, this function
call that I'm going
to have in gRPC,
it's acting on this resource.
And I want to map this
function call to put or post
on this resource.
And the resource
name ends up becoming
arguments or the resource path
ends up becoming arguments
to the function call.
And so you're able to flatten
very nicely gRPC into REST.
And so this gateway, what
it does is it will expose,
not just a REST
endpoint that maps
through gRPC Gateway, but
also an open API, which
was previously known
as Swagger, but it'll
give you a Swagger document.
So you can consume it in
a variety of languages
that already know how to
speak to Swagger-enabled REST
endpoints.
So it's a quite powerful
little framework
if you want to start building
internet accessible APIs.
You get all the best of
the world REST availability
and then the efficiencies and
memory efficiencies of gRPC
for clients that care
highly about that.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
curious, it sounds
like you're using gRPC and
REST for like externals
or like API calls
from external parties.
Does it use it for
internal communications
as well between etcd servers?
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yeah.
So inside of etcd, before we
even started to look at gRPC,
we had already
moved to a streaming
protobuf-based
protocol internally.
So essentially, it's
already HTTP plus protobuf
on the wire as the content type.
And so since the etcd
machines-- there's
only like five or seven of
them in a cluster, essentially
as maximum-- we're
able to stream really
efficiently with single
HTTP connections internally
and already using protobuf.
So we sort of have a
pseudo-gRPC protocol internally.
And we haven't really
had a need to redesign
that because of the
streaming nature
of how etcd actually
does its work.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Is it efficient to expose the
REST APIs through that gateway?
Does it actually
make it much slower
or is it around the same speed
as actually exposing REST
directly?
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yeah.
So there are two considerations.
The first consideration
is that we
do have to do a little bit of
packet sniffing to figure out,
is this an HTTP/1
REST request or is
this an HTTP/2 gRPC request?
That introduces a
tiny bit of latency
on the initial
connection, but it's
a constant time small latency.
So we really don't worry about
that and a couple extra memory
copies.
As far as the efficiency,
yeah, essentially
by using the REST
endpoint, you lose
a lot of the efficiencies
of the new gRPC API.
So you go back to including
and decoding JSON,
and you lose the ability to say
multiplex multiple streaming
requests over the same socket.
So you have that TLS bring
up time and tear down time.
So it is quite a
bit more efficient,
that same 2 to 5x efficiency,
by using the gRPC endpoint.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So at the end of
the day, basically,
what you do is you
expose a gRPC, and people
that care about efficiency,
they will use that one.
And you are basically
getting REST almost for free
for anyone else that wants
the use Swagger or Open API.
BRANDON PHILIPS: Exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
BRANDON PHILIPS: And
there's a huge ecosystem
around Swagger and Open API--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
BRANDON PHILIPS: --and
so it's nice to be
able to bridge that world.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I know
that consuming any API that
exposes a Swagger
definition is very simple,
and there are many
tools for that.
What about a gRPC API?
How do you get started?
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yeah.
So getting started with this
is pretty straightforward.
So there are
protobuf definitions
for-- or gRPC
definitions, I guess,
for etcd that explain
all the function calls
into the remote API.
And then there are
various code generators
that will automatically
create a client binding.
So what we've done
inside of etcd was
we have a Go client
binding, and then we've
wrapped that generated code into
a slightly more nice for humans
to consume API.
And we're doing
similar work for Java.
But if folks want to build,
they can just straight
CodeGen and use the
CodeGen directly.
Or if they want to kind
of wrap it up or super
eager to help people
make easy-to-consume and
human-consumable APIs
for other languages,
the team is eager to help.
MARK MANDEL: Did
you find you had
to do much work from
the generated code
to kind of make it
pretty, so to speak, or--
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yeah.
That's a great question.
So we did a few things.
So etcd has some
transactional semantics.
So we kind of have
transactions where
if this statement holds
true in the database,
then execute this transaction.
If the statement is not true,
then do this other thing.
And you usually have to do a
little bit of semantic work
with closures in et cetera in
order to get that to look nice.
So people can totally
do gets and puts
and the basics of a key value
store with the raw gRPC client,
but once you want to get
into like many transactions
and that sort of
thing, you want to have
something that saves you
from some of the boilerplate
annoyances.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I kind of want
to ask about the streaming API.
Are using it?
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yes.
So etcd v3 has a couple
of streaming endpoints.
The most used or one of the
biggest use cases of etcd
is to actually get a change,
essentially stream of changes,
of all the keys and values.
So let's talk through, say,
how Kubernetes uses this.
So Kubernetes uses etcd
as its primary data store.
A bunch of different
things are happening, say,
service discovery
information is changing,
resources are getting
updated through the REST API.
And you have all these things
that may be caching that data
and want to be invalidated
when something changes.
And so by keeping this
TCB connection open,
you can create these really
dynamic systems based on etcd
where key changes,
and then everyone who
cares about that key
change is immediately
notified without any polling.
And the internal
protocol of etcd
allows for this to be
kind of a safe operation.
You can kind think of
etcd as being like SVN
for your key value stores.
So if you remember like
SVN, the revision system,
every time you made a change,
it incremented the revision
by one.
And so etcd keeps this similar
index or revision internally.
And so you say,
I want all things
that have happened
since revision X,
and then it streams
you back all that.
And then once you get to
the end of the stream,
it just keeps the
stream open, and it
will send you the next stream
from X plus N, wherever
you left off.
MARK MANDEL: So that's
really interesting.
So what did you do before gRPC?
How did you stream that data?
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yeah.
So this is one of the biggest
inefficiencies of etcd
with the REST endpoint was that
we used REST's long polling.
So you would say I
want everything that's
happened since X, and you
would make an HTTP connection,
and we'd stream
everything back since X
and then close the connection.
And then if you said X and
X hasn't happened yet--
this revision
hadn't happened yet.
It's in the future-- we would
just not return an HTTP body.
And once X incremented,
then we would
return you the HTTP body
with all the changes
and then close the
connection again.
And so this is a very
inefficient way of doing it,
but it's essentially how
the entire internet works
today are these extremely
inefficient, constantly
closing HTTP requests.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
That's sounds
really interesting.
So I'm wondering why did
you choose gRPC for etcd,
if it was because you had used
it for something else before
or it was just
because it was faster?
And are you using it
now for other things?
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yeah.
So we ended up choosing gRPC
for essentially two reasons.
One is that we were interested
in HTTP/2 already because
of this long polling thing.
We were pretty dissatisfied
with tearing down
these connections-- these
TLS connections-- every time.
And then we had
already had experience
in using protobuf
internally in etcd
and were super comfortable
with the tooling.
And so gRPC was a
pretty natural fit.
There are also some
legacy reasons.
CoreOS was a very, very early
user of Google App Engine,
and we essentially
had built gRPC
based on a bunch of internal
stuff from Google App
Engine once we had to move
off of Google App Engine.
And so we were
really comfortable
with this REST proxy model
of gRPC Gateway and protobuf
from our experience
almost three years ago.
So it was essentially comfort
with the tooling and confidence
in the tooling that
caused us to choose gRPC
over a lot of the alternatives
that are out there today.
And then the other
big reason was
we wanted to do
this CodeGen stuff,
and we saw that
gRPC was building
a really solid ecosystem of
client binding generation
tools.
And we wanted to see if
we could plug into that,
and that's starting, like I said
earlier, to come to fruition.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And to get to Francesc's
earlier question,
are you using it for
any other projects
or do you plan on using
it for other projects?
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yes.
So we use gRPC in a couple
of different projects.
Rocket is a Container
Engine that we
built and have started to work
with a bunch of other folks
on since then.
And Rocket has an
API service that
exposes a bunch of
information on the host.
So this is stuff
like what images
are available for running?
What are the current statuses
of the containers running
on the host, that sort of thing.
And so we use gRPC
in that service.
And this is one
of the components
that we plug into
Kubernetes-- where
we plug Rocket into Kubernetes.
So Kubernetes is using gRPC
to talk to Rocket today.
And then all of the
internal customer billing
systems for tectonic.com
is all based on gRPC.
As soon as we started to
use gRPC in our open source
projects, a lot of
our back office stuff,
nobody wanted to build
another REST API.
So it started to be adopted
pretty naturally on all
of our back office work too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
That really sounds
like maybe we should
have your back for
a different episode
and have you talk about all
of those different products.
Those sound really cool too.
BRANDON PHILIPS: Cool.
Yeah.
Would be happy to do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I
have one more question,
which is, OK, so
if you did the--
how do you say the word-- the
migration from REST to gRPC,
are there any lessons
that you learned
that you would like to share?
Any painful story
or success story?
BRANDON PHILIPS: So I think
probably the most painful thing
was we pretty rapidly learned
by building a key value
database that people wanted
to store binary data.
And binary data is
really, really hard
to store on a REST API,
particularly key value REST
API, because keys are
really hard to represent.
You end up base64-ing
everything.
And then the values,
you end up having
to somehow generally
base64 or something worse
into JSON bodies.
And so gRPC, because it
has like a native byte type
and can be encoded
into protobufs
has been a pretty big win there.
And then just I think people
underestimate the cost of JSON
in a lot of their systems.
I always joke that the
heat death of the universe
will be caused by
the last JSON being
decoded, just because it's so
expensive to encode and decode
JSON.
There are tricks that you can
do to make it more efficient,
but it does take a lot
of CPU memory to do it.
And if you're
doing it a lot, you
need to consider if there are
more effective ways of doing
it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Cool.
Well, we're sort of running
out of time just a little bit,
but is there anything
that we haven't mentioned
or maybe you would want
to plug or shout-out
to or anything like that?
Anything we might have missed?
BRANDON PHILIPS: No.
The main shout-outs I'd like
to give are etcd and Rocket.
If you want to play
around with gRPC,
there are open source projects.
If you go to
coreos.com/community,
you can find out on IRC channels
and mailing lists how to get
involved.
And then besides that, we have
a couple of upcoming events.
So CoreOS continues to
do a bunch of trainings
around Kubernetes if you want
to learn about that stuff.
It's at coreos.com/training.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
We'll have those links
in the show notes.
BRANDON PHILIPS: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Well thank you so much,
Brendan, for joining us.
It was a really great interview.
I really enjoyed that.
BRANDON PHILIPS: Yeah.
Thank you so much.
And thanks for organizing
everything as well.
Great questions.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
Our pleasure.
MARK MANDEL: It was
a pleasure and a joy
to have Brandon on
the podcast today.
Thanks so much to
him for joining us.
It is really good to hear from
people about how they ended up
at the decision to use
a particular product,
in this case gRPC.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, and
surprisingly how early on they
committed to it.
It was before 1.0, way before.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Way before.
And I used it when it
was before 1.0, and--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
was not that easy.
Now it's much better.
MARK MANDEL: Now it's better.
I was going to say
now it's better.
That's the way I
was going to say it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Huge improvement.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
No, it's a huge
endorsement for the tech.
But why don't we move on to
the Question of the Week.
I think you found a
particularly interesting one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so this is something
that I had to deal
before a couple times.
So imagine that you're
writing an App Engine app--
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--in Go, obviously.
MARK MANDEL: Obviously.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And you
have some of your code
that acts as the
DataStore, and you
want to test that what it's
doing with the DataStore
is correct.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There are
a couple ways of doing this,
but it's actually kind
of easy with App Engine,
because you basically
get this fake DataStore
thing that it's running there.
But what happens if
you're not App Engine?
What if you're using just
the cloud DataStore API?
MARK MANDEL: Oh, and I
might be using like a GKE
instance or something?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Like you're not on App Engine.
Well, before it was
kind of hard to do it.
You needed to basically have
some way of faking a server
or something like that.
And we fixed that by providing
a DataStore emulator.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So it is super simple to use.
If you're using any
of the G Cloud SDKs,
which are available for
many different languages,
but basically you can find
like gcloud-golang, gcloud-node
and all of those.
There are a bunch of
environment variables
that you can set
in your environment
to make your code
point to those instead
to the production for
that kind of environment.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, very nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And to
see which ones they are,
it is actually super simple too.
You just go and run
from G Cloud directly.
You're going to have a command,
which is for now, G Cloud Beta.
So it's G Cloud beta
emulator DataStore something,
and you can run.
And when you run, you start
that server, but also end in it.
And that will give you
a list of variables
that you need to set
in your environment.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, Very handy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
yeah, it is very simple
and will make your tasks that
depend on DataStore much more
reliable because, right
now, if you're doing it
over the network, then you're
depending on the network, which
is not always a good thing.
MARK MANDEL: And
kind of slow and--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So this is going to be much
faster and much more reliable,
which is always good.
MARK MANDEL: Yay, testing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Perfect.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right.
That sounds really good.
Thank you so much,
Francesc, for joining me.
What are you up to?
Are you running away
any time soon working
on any sort of fancy content?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm working on
more content for JustForFunc.
I'm working on two more
episodes, one of them people
really love Go code reviews, so
I'm going to be doing one more.
And then the other one,
I'm still not decided,
but it may be also about
how to write Go code.
Yeah.
Lots of fun.
MARK MANDEL: Lots of fun.
Awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And after that, I'm
going to Brazil in November
for GopherCon Brazil.
MARK MANDEL: Very fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
MARK MANDEL: So when
this episode comes out,
I will have landed in St. Louis.
I will be at Strange Loop.
I'm doing a couple
of things there.
They have a pre-conference
coding dojo where I'll be
teaching Go there--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: --having
lots of fun with that.
And then I'm going to
do a game development
show-and-tell session, which
is basically just show people
games that you're working on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Now that you mentioned
that, actually that
made me think that by the
time this episode comes out,
I will be at GitHub Universe--
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --which I
forgot, because it's not really
travel because it's
in San Francisco.
MARK MANDEL: It's
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But I will be there.
So if there's anyone
else that wants
to talk a little bit
about the cloud or Go,
whatever, come say hi.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Well, again, thanks so much for
joining me on another podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark,
and talk to you and
to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds great.
See you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]